despite the clear military realities on
the ground there is another logic the
military actions should must be to the
defeat of Russia therefore what you're
seeing now is an ongoing War of the West
against Russia until the last Ukrainian
this is something that leaves us no
other option but to continue the aims of
our Smo militarily the Ukrainian people
are suffering from this they're being
used by the west and the criminal
Ukrainian regime as cannon fodder
the fact that the West is not interested
in a political diplomatic settlement of
the Ukrainian crisis being confirmed by
the results of the NATO council meeting
on the 29th and 30th of November in
Bucharest by expanding deliveries of
weapons to Kiev the West is confirming
its desire not only to have a further
escalation of the conflict but to
destabilize the situation in Europe as a
whole
it is now becoming clear that the
uncontrolled pumping of weapons to the
key of regime is becoming a global
problem
without having an actual impact on the
situation on the ground President
Putin's escalating barrages on Ukraine's
infrastructure are evidence that he has
no genuine interest in negotiation or
meaningful diplomacy
instead he is trying to break Ukraine's
will to fight by bombing and freezing
its civilians into submission
but he will not succeed because Ukraine
is fighting for its freedom and for the
future of its children
and we will do everything in our power
to keep hope alive in Ukraine
distinguished colleagues we Harbor no
Illusions about Russian Readiness for
peace
for the time being it is a militarized
and brainwashed Society
ruled by war criminals and educated with
hatred
as long as they have resources they will
continue to attack Ukraine Global
Security architecture and the
international order based on the UN
Charter
Moscow must be deprived of its ability
to produce missiles
to finance military activities in
Ukraine
to threaten the world with the saber
rattling
we encourage responsible and
peace-loving Nations to continue seeking
relevant opportunities to deprive Moscow
of fossil fuel revenues used to finance
the war
in this regard the decision to cap the
price of Russian oil is the first step
in the right direction although the
upper limit requires further adjustments
it is completely useless to bag Moscow
for peace or to appeal to their common
sense
Moscow can only be forced into peace
this is the only language they
understand and respond to
as soon as the strategy is applied by
all sustainable peace as well as the
restoration of respectful principles of
the uncharter will be within reach